the opening scene features two sisters
Kate and Liz who land at Cypress airport
for their vacation Kate being the older
sister takes care of everything for her
younger sister however Liz doesn't want
to be treated like a baby so she often
expresses her frustration towards her
sister she is always on her phone
texting her best friend christe and
complaining about Kate the girl is so
busy with her phone that she forgets the
passports on the bench while leaving the
airport that's why Kate treats you like
a baby stupid after a long drive the
sisters finally reach their hotel during
the check-in process Liz realizes that
she had left the passports at the
airport bench upon learning this Kate
scolds her for being so irresponsible
but Liz starts arguing with her instead
of apologizing for her mistake as the
two fight the receptionist offers them a
solution she will call the port and
retrieve their passports Kate expresses
her gratitude for the help and before
heading towards the room she asks if
it's possible to have some food because
they are starving in response the
receptionist informs them that the
kitchen is already closed and suggests
checking at the nightclub downstairs
later while Kate is in the shower she
receives a call from lizz's Doctor
inquiring about her well-being here it
is revealed that Liz has been suffering
from depression but she is now on the
path to recovery and appears to be doing
better Kate assures the doctor that
she's taking proper care of lizz's
medication after finishing her shower
she steps out of the bathroom and finds
Liz already asleep she opts not to
disturb her and proceeds to the
nightclub alone there she is approached
by a woman named merera who is under
supervision of her boyfriend Jack
unbeknownst to Kate the couple are con
artists who rob people and fund their
lavish lifestyle Meera strikes up a
conversation with Kate and asks if she's
waiting for anyone when the latter
answers in the negative Mera concludes
that she is alone she then asks her for
a dance and our girl reluctantly agrees
to it on the dance floor they are joined
by two local Cy priot uh Andreas and
Nick while the four of them are busy
merera discreetly steals Kate's room key
and secretly passes it to her boyfriend
after some time of dancing Kate captures
some selfies with her new friends and
then intends to leave however she is
stopped by merera who wants her to stay
until Jack finishes stealing the money
from her room at the same time Andreas
mentions that he owns a hot air balloon
and invites everyone for a ride he's a
real Willy Wonka son of a although
hesitant at first Kate eventually agrees
when Andreas points out that it's a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity you'll
never meet this hopeless Ador ever again
the group then gets into his car and
drives to their destination upon arrival
the boys start preparing the hot air
balloon Andreas instructs Nick to tether
a rope to the car's wheel to keep the
balloon stationary Nick follows the
instructions but he forgets to tie the
other end of the Rope to the balloon in
the meantime Jack disguises himself as a
waiter and heads to Kate's room inside
the room Liz awakens to find a picture
of Kate partying with her new friends
and feels hurt she confides in her best
friend about her sister leaving her and
partying alone for the entire night in
order to teach Kate a lesson Liz plans
to play a prank on her she decides to
hide in the closet and make it appear as
if she ditched her following this she
goes to hide inside a closet and at the
same time Jack enters the room with the
stolen key Liz is scared to see the guy
entering the room with a knife and texts
her best friend about the situation a
short while later Jack opens the closet
only to find Liz the girl screams in
horror and rushes into the bathroom
locking herself inside on the other hand
back on the set of Joe Dirt the group
takes off on their hot air balloon and
enjoys the city's scenery from the top
after a while Kate realizes that they
are actually moving she alerts the rest
of the group members and this prompts
Andreas to scold Nick for his negligence
leading to a heated argument between the
two amidst of this Mera notices that the
hot air balloon is moving towards
windmills in a swift move Andreas
increases the flame allowing the balloon
to get up as high as possible to cross
over the windmills following this
everyone crouches low and prays to avoid
a collision at one point Nick stands up
to check the situation but he has no
time to react when a blade from a
windmill strikes the balloon's basket as
a consequence Nick is thrown off while
Andreas is knocked unconscious after a
piece of wood pierces his thigh the two
women urgently search for a first aid
kit but find nothing useful sensing the
urgency of the situation Kate takes off
her shirt because of course and ties it
around andreas' leg to control the
bleeding while the women are in a state
of panic Nick suddenly pops up in the
clouds holding on to the Rope witnessing
this mea tries to reach the rope with
the help of Kate but Nick is unable to
maintain his grip for that long and
eventually falls to his death Willy
Wonka Vibes intensify back at the hotel
Liz comes out from the bathroom and
rushes to the to the front desk she
reports the robbery attempt to the
receptionist and requests that he
contact the police in the meantime Jack
fearing being arrested leaves the hotel
without committing the robbery on his
way to his car he leaves a voicemail for
Meera chastising her for not ensuring
that their target was alone he threatens
her that if he gets arrested he will
break up with her forever shortly after
a police officer arrives at the hotel
and inquires about the incident in
response the receptionist complains that
Liz and her sister arrived at their
hotel without their passports and now
her sister has abandoned the little girl
after regaining Consciousness Andreas
reveals that he isn't permitted to fly
the balloon because it actually belongs
to his boss hearing this Mera explodes
in Anger yelling at him for lying just
for the sake of impressing girls Kate
implores them to stop arguing and focus
on Landing the large balloon instead
however it's already too late as they
are now far from Land flying over the
middle of the ocean okay now this is my
worst nightmare their only option is to
use the warm air and drag themselves
back to the land as time passes Kate
starts getting worried about her sister
who is alone in the hotel room upon
hearing this merera realizes that she
and Jack are in danger of getting caught
by the police before long the group
notices a boat in the distance which
raises their hope of being rescued they
wave and Shout for assistance but the
boat's passengers mistake their gestures
as friendly waves and wave back in the
midst of this Andreas tries to join Kate
and merera but ends up falling into the
water this sends the women into a state
of panic and they begin arguing on who
should jump down with the Rope to rescue
him they waste too much time which
causes Andreas to drown in the water to
make matters worse the boat also starts
leaving in an effort to attract the
boat's attention the duo decides to use
the banner from the balloon they try to
grab it but only manag to detach the
tops which then go even lower following
this Mera has Kate hold on to her legs
as she reaches for the bottom of the
banner she somehow manages to retrieve
it but despite this they have no pen or
marker so Kate resorts to using her own
blood to write an SOS message on it
regrettably their efforts prove futile
as the boat has gone too far away and no
one notices the banner in the aftermath
merera removes her shirt because of
course she does and uses it to wrap
Kate's injured hand in order to stop the
bleeding the scene Cuts back to the
hotel where a police officer summoned an
American Consulate named Sophia she
intends to take Liz into Child
Protection but the girl wants to stay
there and wait for her sister's return
Liz also suspects that her sister might
be in danger because she had shared her
location before disappearing which means
that she hasn't abandoned her Sophia
tries to explain that Liz can't stay at
the hotel any longer and has no
alternative but to accompany her in
response Liz comes up with an idea and
persuades the consulate to set out in
search of Kate following this the two of
them head towards the last location
pinned by Kate which Sophia recognizes
as a tourist destination on the other
hand one cylinder on the hot air balloon
runs out so the women quickly switch the
gas pipes to the other cylinder here
another problem arises they don't have a
match stick to ignite the fire with the
way this movie's logic Works they should
just take their pants off too that would
be hot enough soon after Kate notices a
condom which strikes her with an idea
she fills it with vodka and exposes it
to the sunlight creating a magnifying
glass effect using this trick they
ignite a dollar bill and insert it into
the burner resulting in the hot air
balloon to fly again rarely does a
condom make anyone that happy upon
seeing the smoke generated by the
burning dollar bills Kate comes up with
another plan she wants to create excess
smoke in order to capture attention for
help they then start taking pieces of
the balloon and wrapping it around the
dollar bills to burn it amidst this mea
shares her story about never getting the
the opportunity to go to school and have
a better life she also compliments Kate
on being a strong and independent woman
in the next scene as Liz and Sophia
arrive at the tourist destination they
locate andreas' car inside they discover
a small camera containing video footage
of cner group taking off in the hot air
balloon after this discovery Sophia
contacts the pilot only to learn that
he's on family vacation in the meantime
Mera notices a signaling wire in the
balloon she detaches it and connects it
to Kate's phone which acts as an antenna
the phone then catches a signal and Kate
immediately sends her current location
to her sister moments later the phone
runs out of battery and shuts down
abruptly upon receiving the location Liz
shows it to Sophia and requests that
they head in that direction Sophia
agrees and the two soon arrive at the
Port they then hop into a dinghy and set
off towards the indicated location by
this time the hot air balloon has landed
on the water leading to a state of panic
for the two women seeing death in front
of her eyes Mera bursts into tears and
confesses how she and her boyfriend
planned to break into Kate's hotel room
by stealing her key card despite this
Revelation Kate isn't angry at her but
she's more concerned about her sister
elsewhere Jack retrieves some of his
hidden money and drives away in his car
with his other girlfriend they stop at a
hotel and while Jack is in the shower
his so-called new girlfriend steals all
of his money and Cary before fleeing the
scene the hot air balloon is now
completely in the water Kate manages to
swim out of it but mea seems to be stuck
inside realizing that she cannot swim
Kate swims back and rescues her just in
time they then cling to a floating
cylinder and wait for help not long
after they spot a large cargo ship
approaching raising their hopes of being
finally rescued however the captain and
the other passengers can't see them due
to the larger ship size as a result the
ship passes by leaving the two of them
stranded yet again meanwhile the ding's
engine stops working leaving Liz and
Sophia stranded in the middle of the
ocean despite the setback Liz doesn't
give up and remains determined to find
her sister she hands sopia a rowing
paddle and they continue the rest of
their journey by rowing after a long
while they arrive at the pinned location
they find no one in sight a clever Liz
then uses air horn signals to create
loud noises Kate and merera can hear the
sound but are unable to respond loudly
enough right then merera uses her
grandmother's lucky mirror to reflect
sunlight pinpointing their exact
location finally Liz and Sophia locate
the two of them and row towards their
Direction immediately they pull them on
board and there's an emotional reunion
between the two sisters they introduce
each other to their new best friends and
the movie ends as the four make their
way back subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for
watching